Wenn man uns anschaut ... Ich nehme
dich als sehr pflichtbewusst wahr.
Du bist weniger inkonsequent
als ich.
Es ist interessant: Eine solche
Aussage ist heute fast ein Vorwurf.
Es schwingt mit, dass ich eine
langweilige, moralinsaure Tante bin.
Nein! Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich musste feststellen,
dass ich sehr inkonsequent bin.
Viele meiner Vorsätze
halte ich nicht ein:
weniger Fleisch essen,
mehr meditieren,
weniger billige Kleidung kaufen usw.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es gut oder schlecht ist,
etwas inkonsequent zu sein.
In der Frage,
wie inkonsequent man sein darf,
gibt es zwei Probleme,
die vermischt werden.
Für die einen gilt:
Wenn ich ein Prinzip habe
und sicher bin, dass es richtig ist,
wie z.B. das Unterlassen
von Lästereien über Freunde,
ist es falsch, dagegen zu verstossen.
Dann ist inkonsequent sein
meiner Meinung nach
eine moralische Willensschwäche -
und das ist nicht gut.
Willensschwäche heisst,
du bist zu wenig stark.
Du bist nicht in der Lage,
dich an das zu halten,
was du für richtig befindest.
Der andere Fall ist, dass wir
glauben, wir seien inkonsequent,
aber eigentlich
haben wir dieses Prinzip gar nicht.
Das ist viel öfter der Fall.
Der Klassiker:
Menschen
wollen weniger Fleisch essen.
Auf einer Grillparty
schaffen sie es trotzdem nicht,
den Hähnchenschenkel liegen zu lassen
und den Tofuburger zu nehmen.
Die meisten Menschen würden sagen:
Ich finde es wichtig,
weniger Fleisch zu essen,
aber die anderen essen auch -
weshalb sollte ich es nicht tun?
Daran sieht man, dass das Prinzip,
dass man nicht Fleisch essen darf,
von vielen Menschen
nicht anerkannt ist.
Das ist der Streitpunkt
zwischen Platon und Aristoteles.
Platon sagte, wenn du das Gute
eingesehen hast, tust du es auch.
Und diejenigen, die es nicht machen,
haben es nicht eingesehen.
Aristoteles
spricht von Willensschwäche.
Er akzeptiert, dass es so was gibt.
Dass stärkere Impulse kommen können.
Willensschwäche gibt es zweifelsohne.
Sonst hätten wir
keine Gewissensbisse.
Ja.
Wir sehen das Richtige ein,
handeln aber doch nicht danach.
Und dann haben wir ein
schlechtes Gewissen und grübeln nach.
Es kann auch schön sein,
etwas Verbotenes zu tun,
einen Vorsatz zu brechen -
dann fühlt man sich lebendig.
Die Frage ist, wie viele Ausnahmen
moralische Regeln zulassen.
Wie gehst du damit um?
Wenn man aus Prinzip
für sich entschieden hat,
nicht mehr zu fliegen,
und dann fliegt man trotzdem,
ist es ein Akt der Willensschwäche.
Man kann sich fragen,
ob jemand sympathischer ist,
der ab und zu Willensschwäche zeigt.
Immer nur moralische Prinzipien
zu verfolgen ist doch auch seltsam.
Das ist der Ansatz von Susan Wolf im
Aufsatz "Die moralischen Heiligen".
Sie schreibt, unsere Welt
sei uninteressant und langweilig,
wenn alle nur moralischen Prinzipien
folgen würden
und nicht auch noch anderes tun.
Aber sie meint damit nicht,
dass wir moralische Prinzipien
verletzen sollen.
Sie meint, dass es in unserem Leben
noch andere Werte gibt.
Ich darf also auch mal
in ein teures Konzert gehen
und muss nicht
mein letztes Hemd spenden.
Wenn wir glauben, dass wir gewisse
Dinge nicht mehr tun dürfen ...
Wie bringen wir uns dahin?
Wir könnten beispielsweise
Rechtsnormen festlegen.
Irgendwann wurde gesagt: Normale
Glühbirnen brauchen zu viel Strom,
sind eine Belastung fürs Klima,
also werden sie vom Markt genommen.
Es gibt nur noch Sparlampen.
Standardmässig.
- Dann kann man nicht mehr ...
- ... das Falsche wählen.
Das ist eine Möglichkeit.
Wie weit sollte man gehen
mit Soft-Law-Prinzipien,
mit weichem Recht,
mit sog. Default Positions,
mit sog. Nudging, einem Anstupsen,
oder mit einer Rechtsnorm?
Default Position beim Ausdrucken
von Papier - ein super Beispiel.
Die meisten Menschen
haben immer einseitig ausgedruckt.
Jetzt kann man bei Druckern
einstellen,
dass Papier standardmässig
doppelt bedruckt wird.
In den Unternehmen
wird weniger Papier gebraucht.
Klar. Und es schränkt
die Freiheit nicht ein.
Viele unserer Probleme können wir
nur gemeinschaftlich lösen -
in einer fairen Aufteilung
der moralischen Arbeit,
die wir leisten müssen.
Das macht es sehr komplex.
Die Sachen hängen zusammen.
Wenn du heute eine Avocado kaufst,
musst du dir bewusst sein,
dass sie auf einer Plantage gezüchtet
und eingeflogen wurde.
- Es braucht viel Wasser.
- Das stresst mich.
Ich hätte es lieber,
der Staat würde mir Grenzen setzen:
In diesem Rahmen darf ich machen,
was ich will.
- Wir sind doch
keine Kindergartenkinder. - Aber ...
Das empfinde ich
als pure Überforderung.
So viel Autonomie,
so viel moralische Verantwortung
auf den Einzelnen abzuwälzen ...
Vielleicht haben wir die heute,
weil wir so viel wissen
und bewirken könnten.
Für mich ist das aber
ein Ohnmachtsgefühl.
Ich persönlich finde die ganze Klage
dieses Moralismus,
der so anstrengend und komplex ist,
empfinde ich als etwas weinerlich.
Wir hatten noch nie
so viel Freizeit wie heute.
Die Menschen sind extrem frei.
Vielleicht können wir nicht so gut
mit dieser Freiheit umgehen.
Das kann schwierig sein.
Ich finde sehr konsequente Menschen
oft bewundernswert
und gar nicht besonders schräg.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl,
man spricht schnell von Moralterror,
vom Moralisten, der herumläuft und
mit der Moralkeule auf Leute drescht.
Da sage ich sofort:
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Aber der Moralist hat das Problem,
dass er andere mit der Keule schlägt.
Dass er sein Handeln
an seinen Prinzipien misst
und konsequent ist, ist nicht falsch.
- Es ist einschüchternd.
- Gib mir doch ein Beispiel.
Wir sind doch Wesen,
die Verlockungen erliegen.
Klar.
Wir verlieren einen Moment lang
die Kontrolle usw.
Das ist doch das Leben
und das Menschsein.
Kontrollverlust klingt danach,
als sei das ganze Leben zugepflastert
mit moralischen Normen -
das glaube ich nicht.
Es kommt mir oft so vor.
Alles ist moralisch aufgeladen.
Beim Einkaufen die Frage,
welchen Salat ich nehme,
die Frage, welche Schuhe ich trage,
wie ich zur Arbeit gehe ...
Alles ist derzeit
politisch und moralisch aufgeladen.
- Man hat das Gefühl, es sei ...
- Yves, du darfst alles.
Du darfst kaufen, was du willst.
Du darfst das alles.
Aber es ist alles moralisch
bewertbar, ich kann Fehler machen
und dafür angegriffen werden.
- Ja. Das Leben ist komplex.
Es wird suggeriert, cool seien jene,
die über die Stränge schlagen.
Aber es ist etwas anderes,
ob man sich mal auf einer Party
daneben benimmt, weil man
die Konsequenzen nicht scheut,
weil man
nicht so obrigkeitsgläubig ist.
Davon halte ich viel.
Aber ein anständiges Leben führen?
Ein moralisch richtiges Leben.
Ich finde, das steht uns gut.
Ich sehe nicht ein,
was daran falsch sein sollte.
Vielleicht
redet man sich auch etwas ein.
Angenommen,
ich bin eher inkonsequent,
eine eher willensschwache Person,
die irgendwelche Vorsätze verletzt.
Dann rede ich mir ein,
dass es gar nicht so schlimm ist,
damit ich abends
in den Spiegel schauen kann.
Damit es
keine kognitive Dissonanz gibt.
Ich bin inkonsequent, aber
auf einer höheren Stufe finde ich,
Inkonsequenz ist etwas Menschliches.
Wenn euch das interessiert:
Am philosophischen Stammtisch
sprachen wir über die Position
des effektiven Altruismus.
Es gibt Menschen, die sagen,
wir sollen mit unseren Handlungen
möglichst viel Gutes bewirken.
Und wir haben
mit Ernst Fehr gesprochen,
einem berühmten Verhaltensökonomen,
der zeigt, wie wir unseren Egoismus
austricksen und uns
zum guten Handeln bewegen können.
Da könnt ihr nachschauen.